Ja wir berichten hier ja regelmäßig über den hyper lob von elon musk
Jetzt gibt es neuigkeiten in diesem bereich denn ein staatskonzern in china will einen eigenen hyper lob entwickeln der mit achtung
4000 kilometern pro stunde rast der name hyper flight ihr habt euch dieses thema whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt alle wichtigen weg zu
dieser krassen idee wie genau soll diese transporttechnik funktionieren und wie
Realistisch sind die pläne aus china das alles und noch viel mehr natürlich jetzt sind wir zu dem science fiction herzlich willkommen
Zunächst einmal sollen die geplanten fliegenden züge in einer luftröhre mit 1000 kilometern pro stunde wichtige städte in china
verbinden passagiere könnten dann in 30 minuten die
1100 kilometer von peking nach
wuhan zum beispiel in central china reisen doch schon in naher zukunft sollen dann auch
internationaler trassen entstehen mit unglaublichen 4000 kilometern pro stunde soll das projekt hyper flight dann in richtung
westen und auch nach europa ausgebaut werden das alles melden die staatliche nachrichtenagentur
kuna und die zeitung china morning post aus hongkong
im vergangenen jahr der plan kommt von chinas staatlichem raumfahrtkonzern china aerospace science and industry coporation
K sieg demnach soll mehr als 20
chinesische und internationale
forschungsgruppen an diesem projekt arbeiten und in china werden solche entwicklung mit viel höherem druck
Vorangetrieben als im westen hier muss ihnen masia sie sogar zum teil gegen widerstände durch trinken ja
4000 kilometer pro stunde das ist schon echt der absolute wahnsinn ich hätte euch mal vor die höchstgeschwindigkeit von airbus 380 liegt bei
1000 20 kilometern pro stunde und die der boeing 787 bei 9 154
kilometern pro stunde die transporttechnik soll wohl ähnlich wie beim heimflug von spacex
Chef elon musk funktionieren darüber berichten welche ja regelmäßig der würde bei den angeblichen
höchstgeschwindigkeiten von 4000 kilometern pro stunde galt allerdings wirken wie ein bummelzug
Genau wie der hyper lob soll der hyper flight in einer weitestgehend
luftleeren röhre unterwegs sein so dass der luftwiderstand reduziert werden oder fast keine rolle mehr spielt dadurch dass sich der geplante
fliegen dazu per
magnetschwebetechnik fortbewegt entsteht keine reibung in dem offiziellen statement des technischen leiters markt
Heißt es half life wird die transportzeit zwischen städten verkürzen
witterungseinflüssen trotzen und den verbrauch fossiler brennstoffe
vermeiden er
repräsentiert die zukunft der transport der beschleunigungs und
bremsvorgänge seien darauf ausgelegt dass die passagiere es ohne probleme aushalten doch das projekt wirft zahlreiche ungelöste fragen auf wie kann
man diese technik erdbebensicher machen wie lässt sich die sicherheit der 1000 und mehr kilometer lange
vakuumröhren sicherstellen wie lässt sich ein dermaßen schneller zug
schnell und sicher abbremsen zu diesen fragen und anderen technischen schwierigkeiten allerdings gibt es keine offiziellen aussagen
Die pläne sind also bislang mehr als wahre die chinesen selbst jedenfalls äußern sich auf sozialen plattformen
durchaus kritisch denn darüber haben wir ja auch schon berichtet
chinas städte sind vollgestopft mit autos dann kommt kaum voran und der smog führt zu einigen tools fans deswegen
fragen sich viele ob es nicht andere drängendere
baustellen in den staugeplagten
Städten gäbe könnte die regierung zuerst mal ideen entwickeln um die nervige stausituation
Zu lösen ich brauche eine stunde um von der fünften zur dritten
Umgehungsstraße zu fahren ja das heißt so in einem user postings peking wenn ihr als erstes neues zu diesem thema
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion von kriegs- und mitmachen und themen wie dieses hier vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken hyper loop rekord durch deutsches team ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran